[Music]
you
hallo YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my 41
episode of chest rap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profile trap in the
modern Scandinavian variation from the
white perspective the opening arises
after the following model he fo b phi he
captures d phi and now rather than
taking back with the queen black choose
the other option namely Knight to f6
okay the mainline continue with d4 and
wipes Big Ideas when black recapture
de-spawn he wants to play c4 not only
attacking denied but grabbing every
single space in the center of the board
well by far the most popular choice is
night to be six and after that here my
recommendation is you should continue
with Knight to f3
now if you check this position in online
database black has tried majority two of
this moves announced them if your
opponent continue with g6 then in my
past I have created a video named as
handling various Scandinavian defenses
so if you haven't check it out I
strongly insist you to watch that video
which will give you a very good idea how
to play against the move g6
but more often than not you are going to
face the move Bishop to g4 as this move
looks very logical not only it's
attacking denied but there's a huge
pressure going on on the d4 pawn here my
proposal is you should continue with
first c5 asking the question to this
knowledge and once again if you opponent
continue it Knight to d7 then that leads
to very passive play by black
so that's why majority of the games
continue with defy which at first sight
looks very logical as black has
centralizes night at the center of the
table however believe it or not but
black has straightaway fallen into
White's trap identity
the trapping business start with this
very cute move Queen to b3
so clearly white is attacking the b7
pawn and accordingly as I highlighted
over here black has tried various
responses but I'm afraid all of them are
miserably failed and white can't winning
advantage just within the opening stage
the first move I want to consider is b6
which is obviously a bad move and the
simple refutation goes as follow Knight
to e5 attacking the bishop kindly note
that this bishop can never go to d7 as
the defy Knight will hang and a part for
me if it goes to anywhere else let's say
Bishop to b6 we have this following nice
sequence Bishop to b5 check
see six is the only response which will
not lose a piece but after that yup you
guess it
night capture see six attacking the
Queen as well as ready for the discover
check
so by force black has to take this piece
but after Bishop capture c6 Bishop to d7
[Music]
nope we are not going to grab the rook
in the corner but first we are capturing
this night which is fortunately also
threatening of maid so black has to stop
the maid first with a six and just after
that Bishop captures rook Queen takes
and now castle
and if you count the material at the
14th move of the game white obtained the
whole hook isn't that wonderful
the second move I want to consider is
Bishop captures f3 which is again one of
the bad choice by black has white is not
forced to recapture this piece
immediately and instead of that should
perform this accurate move Queen
captures b7 attracting rook
well tactical move Bishop captures g2
doesn't work here because of the simple
Bishop captures g2 and now few of the
black pieces are hanging with a very bad
position so that is right out of the
equation so that means black has to save
the rope with Knight to d7 but after
that the simplest mu in the world pawn
captures f3 and at the end of the
sequence not only white get extra pawn
but we are still pressurizing this night
and one of my blitz game against the
2000 rated opponent give you a very good
idea how good this position is for the
white my opponent responded with a 6
defending the knight I played Knight to
c3
pressurizing this night and after the
following sequence Knight captures c3
pawn captures c3 Bishop to e7 and now
Bishop to a4
you got the answer of all of your
questions and the next few moves we are
going to play Bishop to g3 Bishop to c4
and then castle on the Kings side we're
with this bishop pair and a healthy pawn
advantage black is clearly suffering in
the upcoming middle
you
the third move Bishop to c8 already
looks very funny because black has
wasted so much time with this bishop
however you should also know how to meet
this move and my recommendation here is
Bishop to g5 pinning down the e7 pawn
our plan is very obvious we want to play
Bishop to c4 pressurize this night and
continue with our very fast piece
development
well again I just like to highlight how
problematic this position is for the
black has in the database one of the
game continued with at six attacking the
bishop but why doesn't bother about it
and continue with Bishop to c4
he six is not possible so black thought
okay I will capture this Bishop which
will give me the OpenEdge file but the
net result is after Bishop captures defy
attacking on f7 and when black defend
with a six he get this rude shock yup
you got it
Bishop captures b7 Bishop captures b7
Queen captures me seven attacking the
room and after night to b7 and the move
Queen to c6 again white emerged with an
extra pawn and a better position
last but not least the most critical
response here is Knight to c6 and after
that our response is force yup we are
going to grab this pawn with Queen
captures b7 and now again Black has to
be very careful he doesn't have time to
cap to this night as c6 Knight hangs
with a check so accordingly Black has
two choices
well if we continue with night C goes to
the be four square then this is pretty
bad
as after this Bishop check more or less
black and resigned the game both c6 and
Bishop to d7 are not working here if he
continued with c6 then the easiest
movies Bishop captures c6 nycap to c6
win capture c6 and black is forced to
block with the bishop and after that
Queen captures defy gives white a whole
piece and to pawn advantage
same goes for the Bishop to d7 as after
Bishop comes as g7 black can't capture
with the Queen as the rook in the corner
hangs so by force black has to capture
with the King but after that Queen to be
fuschak c6 now we can play Knight and if
I check and after King to e8 and the
move Queen to b4
again and again in this line might
become a pawn advantage and this time
this is even lethal as Blackie is
permanently stuck in the center of the
pole
finally let's check out what we are
going to do against blacks most critical
response Knight d2 B form
so not only black is supporting the
snide but he's threatening the moon
night to see to check
and maybe you think that we have to save
the folk right well of course not as we
are going to continue with our
aggressive style Bishop to be far
black is forced to play Bishop to d7 but
instead of that if he continued with
this foolish moves such as night to see
to check then after the following
sequence came to a funny now the night
is hanging so Bishop to d7 is forced but
guess what
Bishop capture c6 hand black is
completely busted due to the multiple
threat in this position
for example if he captured this bishop
then after the following sequence Quinn
capture c6 Queen to d7 Quinn captures
air check Queen to d8 Queen captures a7
and finally after Knight captures even
the dust is clear and white obtain a
piece and a two extra pawn advantage
and instead of capturing the bishop here
if black tried to save the roof with
rook to c8
then he get the huge trouble with the
whites next amazing reply Knight d5
so this Bishop is completely trapped and
the funny part is if he continued with
Bishop capture c6
then after queen capture c6 Queen to d7
and Queen captures d7 we have a picture
as checkmate over the ball
so you can see if you oppor and continue
with night to see to check then disaster
is looming in just within few Mo's the
best response for the black here is he
has to play Bishop to d7 to safeguard
the c6 Knight and now we reach to one of
the critical position of this line
amazingly enough if you put this
position in any chess engine it will
tell you that after d-file white is
completely winning however it is bit
complicated and if you are interested in
this variation then I have attached a
sample line in the PGN but instead of
that here my recommendation is you play
this very simple sequence which doesn't
require any memorization and at the end
white still get or healthy advantage
why it should start with Bishop capture
c6 which forces black to recapture with
the night and after that the
consolidating move 26 so what we achieve
is first of all we are held upon up and
the second we have removed all the
complications and achieve a very good
position so that way over the board we
shouldn't have any problem to convert
this into the winning advantage
let me show you few accurate moves by
black and how good y-position become
night two before attacking the Queen as
well as looking at the juicy see two
square
well Queen to see four counter-attacking
tonight rook to b8 and finally white
eject this Knight with a three
after Bishop to e6 Queen twee to Knight
to c6 attacking the d4 pawn when white
defend with Bishop to e3 just look at
this position not only white has a
healthy pawn advantage but black has
some fracture pawn on the Queen side and
once white managed to castle I think
with the accurate play this is
definitely a huge advantage to the white
camp
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile trap in the
modern Scandinavian variation remember
when you open and churn out this logical
moon night to defy hit him with this
crafty move Queen to b3
and no matter however black wriggles
white obtain the winning advantage just
within the opening stage
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care